this house is full of surprises sliding
or pivoting panels transform each space
they can be found throughout the entire
structure this is the Murphy house
designed and owned by architect Richard
Murphy
in 2016 it was named House of the Year
by the Royal Institute of British
Architects
[Music]
there are lots of ideas behind this
house how it fits into a piece of
historic Edinburgh how it changes
between winter and summer how you get a
lot of rooms into a very small space how
you save energy and how an architect
really brings to bear his own influences
and interests of other architects he's
studied it's quite a limited volume of
space so the shape of the house came
from that building up high on one side
and low on the other and then try to as
I say get us lots of many rooms in there
as possible and using various devices to
make the house feel bigger that it
actually is the Murphy house and it's
unique architecture certainly stands out
in Edinburgh as popular Newton district
most of the houses here were built in
the 19th century and represent the
world's largest example of uninterrupted
late Georgian architecture the Murphy
house has eight levels spread over five
storeys with a hundred and forty square
meters of living space
it took Richard Murphy a total of ten
years to build his house from seeing the
sight drawing up the plans to getting
the building permits
the master bedroom is located on the top
floor and also contains large moveable
panels here too there is an element of
surprise
it's a small house and spaces of premium
but I want to have a bath somewhere in
the house so I thought why don't up with
a bath in the bedroom but I disguised it
as a seat this is a panel which opens up
between the bedroom and the living room
I mean one does things for different
reasons sometimes you do them for
functional reasons and sometimes you do
them for a piece of fun this is more of
a piece of fun so that when you're in
the bedroom you can talk to people down
in the living room if you want to the
reason it's designed like this which is
the eccentric pivot is because you don't
want to be able to see straight ahead
because if you saw straight ahead you'll
be able to see from the bed into the
neighbors windows which is not such a
clever idea there was a long period of
time when it looked like the Murphy
house would never be built after a lot
of wrangling with the Planning
Department they actually recommended
refusal but I went and talked to a
couple of local councilors who are on
the Planning Committee and they
understood what I was trying to do and
they talk to other councillors and when
we got to the committee meeting the
councilors overturned the recommended
refusal the language bar which is
extremely rare the house doesn't really
blend in so what did the neighbors think
they all complained of course all lots
of them did anyway and there was a bit
of a campaign but almost there to quote
Shakespeare they campaigned a little bit
too much actually and I think that
rebounded a bit on the councillors
having finished the house I've had
exactly the opposite reaction from
neighbors they all loved it
Murphy's use of concrete levels and
geometric shapes were inspired by the
late Italian architect carlo scarpa even
here out in a garden there is great
attention to detail
a walk from top to bottom helps give the
visitor a better idea of all the details
of the house Richard Murphy has lived in
his house for two and a half years now
and he wouldn't change a thing if he had
to build it all over again